the Joe Rogan experience look he was
fine the way Deontay Wilder does who
cares if he's from the moon right you
start some people like that like we want
to see that guy fight you don't care if
that guy's from [ __ ] Brazil wherever
he's from goodnight god damn it's one of
those punches where people just go that
you see people in the audience he hits
hard even when he don't fully extend it
be like crazy thing is when he fought
Tyson Fury he was 209 209 that's nothing
any punch is so [ __ ] hard it's crazy
that 2 is so an anomaly the fact that he
won a bronze medal in the Olympics three
years after taking up boxing right said
said insane it's just insane yeah
because there are a lot of people they
asked me because we was in the same you
know trials in 2007 it was like do you
ever remember Deonte water and an
amateur's I said man he came out of
nowhere
cracking people say he never went on
none of the duels or nothing he just
came out of nowhere
yeah he's all the top guys in a
heavyweight division crazy that's uh I'd
say he's a unicorn you know when you
look at his record what is it like
thirty nine knockouts out of 41 fights
this up like that 49 49 coats at 41
fights it was all as four year came
there you know yes - only two fights
went with what is it the first one was
at Brazil don't know no Brazil he just
knocked out who was who went the
distance
Steve urns burn went the distance in
their first fight so burn yeah and then
he flatlined him in the second fight
that crazy one
so he hits - flying man
people go flying he got the lat he got
the right last name yeah Wow
was he good while he started
how about that in who to this day the
film was like [ __ ] what did I do
and then he was his hashtag till this
day he uses that all the time on his
Instagram so that guys get shell shocked
he gets PTSD every time is funny no
because we all we all be saying that now
like today's day I'm going back to that
that story so our vices he took that
phrase over it that was a that was a
phrase you know that he just owned he
took it over that's his name all right
that's it that's it say that's his one
interview one interview one interview
before a fight was getting geared up but
you see the look oh my god you know how
hard that guy hits and he's about to
knock me out for sure 100% he would
never do that it's like you'd be ear in
the room with a lion like oh no and he's
aggressive mr. lion
oh you sure this thing's trained you
sure it's not gonna eat me
he's so that must have been terrifying
I don't like please Blaine there's fully
geared up and ready for war before this
fight